hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to doki doki literature
club now it's the day of the festival
and i have a funny feeling that things
are going to be bad uh sayori isn't here
i considered going to her house to wake
her up but decide that's a little too
much yeah
definitely why would that be i need help
getting the cupcakes down there
meanwhile the preparations for the event
should be nearly complete i managed to
carry all the cupcakes by myself by
carefully stacking two trays natsuki is
already texting up a storm but i can't
respond thanks to my hands being full
funnily enough i probably feel the same
way as natsuki about the event i'm more
excited for it to be over so i can spend
time with siori nitsuki at the festival
but knowing monica i'm sure the event
will be great too
morp yes you're the first one here
thanks for being early that's funny i
thought at least yuri would eat a beer
by now monica's placing a little booklet
it is really quiet it is really really
quiet it is really quiet
really quiet monica is placing little
booklets on each of the desks in the
classroom they must be the one she
prepared that has all the poems we're
performing in the end i found a random
poem online that i thought monica would
like and submitted it so that's the one
i'll be performing i'm surprised you
didn't bring sayori with you yeah she
overflapped again that dummy
you'd think that on a day is important
to this you try a little harder i say
that but i suddenly remember what sierra
told me yesterday and i suddenly feel
awful knowing it's not nearly that
simple for her yeah i should have gone
to her house huh i only said it because
it's the way i'm used to thinking but
maybe i should have gone to wake her up
after all yeah you think dummy
you should take a little responsibility
for her more i mean especially after
your exchange with her yesterday you
kind of left her hanging this morning
you know exchange monica you know about
that of course i do i'm the club
president after all
that doesn't explain anything monica i
stammer embarrassed did siri really tell
her about it that quickly that we're a
couple now i didn't really plan on
bringing it up with anyone yet geez you
don't know the full story at all so
don't worry i probably know a lot more
than you think
monica is being as friendly as usual but
for some reason there's a chill down my
spine after hearing that hey do you want
to check out the pamphlets they came out
really nice it's really quiet okay yeah
sure i grab one on the plant food so lay
down on the desk yeah they really did
something like this will definitely help
people take the club more seriously uh
yeah i thought so too flipped through
the pages each member's poem is neatly
printed on its own page giving it an
almost professional feel i recognize
natsuki and yuri's poem from the ones
they performed during our practice
what's this i've flipped to sayuri's
poem it's different from the one she
practiced
it's one that i haven't read before
oh
get out of my head
get out of my head before i do what i
know is best for you get out of my head
before i listen to everything she said
to me get out of my head before i show
you how much i love you get out of my
head before i finish writing this poem
but a poem is never actually finished it
just stops moving
ah
what is this ringing the poem i get a
pit in my stomach ooh hi morp what's
wrong oh nothing this poem feels
completely different from everything
else they've always written
but more than that i i changed my mind
i'm gonna go get sorry i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go get siri well well all right
try not to take too long okay okay
quickly leave the classroom don't strain
yourself
monica calls that out after me that's
weird quick in my pace oh what the hell
it's so quiet what was i thinking i
should have tried a little bit harder
for sayori it's not a big deal to at
least wait for her or help wake her up
even the simple gesture of walking into
her school makes her really happy
besides i told her yesterday that things
will be the same as they always have
been that's all she needs and what i
want to give her every series has a
knock on the door i don't expect an
answer since she's not picking up her
phone either like yesterday i opened the
door and let myself in
see ori she really is a heavy sleeper i
swallow can't believe i ended up doing
this after all waking her up in her own
house that really is something that a
boyfriend would do isn't it in any case
it just feels right outside sierra's
room i knock on her door say ori wake up
dummy there's no response i really
didn't want to have to enter a room like
this isn't it kind of a breach of
privacy which really leaves me no choice
i gently open the door
[Music]
oh
ah
[Music]
what the hell
is this a nightmare it has to be this
isn't real there's no way this could be
real sorry i wouldn't do this oh man i
got chills down my spine that everything
was normal up until a few days ago
okay that's why i can't believe what my
eyes are showing me
oh i suppressed the urge to vomit just
yesterday i told sarah i would be there
for her i told her i know what's best
and that everything will be okay then
why why would she do this how could i be
so helpless what did i do wrong
confessing to her i shouldn't have
confessed to her that's not what ceora
needed at all she even told me how
painful it is for others to care about
her then why did i confess to her and
make her feel even worse why was i so
selfish it's my fault my swarming
thoughts keep telling me everything i
could have done to prevent this if i
just spend more time with her walked her
to school and remained friends with her
like i always has been then i could have
prevented this i know i could have
prevented this screw the literature club
go to the festival i just lost my best
friend oh my god
someone i grew up with she's gone
forever now nothing i can do can bring
her back this isn't some game where i
can reset and try something different i
had only one chance and i wasn't careful
enough and now i'll carry this guilt
with me until i die nothing in my life
is worth more than hers but i still
couldn't do what she needed from me and
now i can never take it back
never never never never never
[Music]
i see an annoying girl running towards
me from the distance
oblivious to the attention she might
draw to herself that girl is
my neighbor and good friend since we
were children you know the kind of
friend you never see yourself making
today but it just works out because you
kind of known each other we used to walk
each other to school but starting to
grow she was oversleep more and more
frequently i get tired of waiting up but
she's gonna chase after me i almost feel
better off running away however i just
sigh and idle let catch up to me ho ha
whoa hey whoa whoa whoa hate this oh i
hate this i don't like that
it's an ordinary school day like any
other mornings are usually the worst
being surrounded by couples and friends
who walk to school meanwhile i've always
walked to school alone
always always always tell myself it's
about time i meet some girls or
something like that but i have no
motivation to join any clubs i'm
perfectly connected just getting by on
the average while submitting free time
on games and anime it's always been the
anime club it's not worth no girls in it
anyway
okay all right what the hell is
happening the girl at school is as
ordinary as ever and it's over before i
know it after i pack up my things i
start blanking at the wall looking for
an ounce of motivation clubs there
really aren't any that interest me
besides most of them would probably be
way way too demanding for me to want to
deal with i guess i have no choice but
to start the it's the anime club
morph
hi monica
hi oh my goodness i totally didn't
expect to see you here it's been a while
right ah
yeah it has monica smiles sweetly we do
know each other well we rarely talk but
we were in the same class last year
monica was probably the most popular
girl in school in class smart beautiful
athletic basically completely out of my
league so having her smile at me so
genuinely feels a little
what did you come in here for anyway
i've just been looking for some supplies
i used for my club do you know if
there's any construction paper in here
or markers i guess you could check the
closet you're in the debate club right
about that i actually quit the debate
club really you quit yeah to be honest i
can't stand all the politics around the
major clubs feels like nothing but
arguing about the budget and publicity
about how to prepare for events i'd
rather much rather take something i
personally enjoy make something special
out of it in that case what club did you
decide to join actually i'm starting a
new one
that sounds kind of dull how many
members do you have so far
it's kind of embarrassing but there's
only three of us so far it's really hard
to find new members for something that
sounds so boring well i can see that but
it's really not boring at all you know
literature club can be anything reading
poetry writing i mean one of my new
mavericks keeps her manga collection
hidden in the club room wait really yeah
it's funny right she always insists that
manga is literature too the idiot i'm
guessing she's not wrong but yeah
besides the new members of members right
did monica say she hmm hey more any
chance are you still looking for a club
to join
ah i mean i guess so but in that case is
there any chance you could do me a big
favor i want to ask you to join but if
you could at least be very at least
visit my club it would make it me really
happy
please
um
i guess i have no reason to reviews
besides how could i ever refuse someone
like mark how could how could i how
could i oh oh oh oh oh
ah
my saves
my set my saves my saves are gone
my saves are gone
my shaves are gone i'm gonna ever refuse
someone like monica sure i guess i could
check it out
awesome you're really sweet morph you
know that it's nothing really i'm just
full of sugar
anyway shall we go then i'll look for
new materials another time you're more
important
okay
and thus today marks the day i sold my
soul to monica and her irresistible
smile
i timidly follow monica across the
school in upstairs the section of
school i rarely visit being generally
used for third year classes in activity
monica full of energy swings open the
classroom door
i'm
back and i brought a guest with me
a guest
seriously you bought a boy
way to kill the atmosphere don't be mean
natsuki but anyway welcome to the club
morp
okay all the words escape me in this
situation this club is full of
incredibly cute girls so let me guess
you're monica's boyfriend right right no
i'm not natsuki the girl with a sour
attitude whose name is apparently
natsuki is one i don't recognize her
small figure makes me think she's a
first year anyway this is natsuki
energetic as usual and this is yuri the
vice president it's nice to meet you
yuri who appears comparably more mature
and timid seems to have a hard time
keeping up with someone like natsuki
yeah it's nice to meet both of you so i
ran into morph in a classroom and
decided to come check out the club isn't
that great wait monica didn't i tell you
to let me know in advance before you
brought in anyone new
i was gonna well you know sorry sorry i
didn't forget about that but i just
happened to run into them in that case i
should at least make them tea right yeah
that would be great why don't you come
sit down more okay girls have a few
deaths arranged to form a table yuri
walks to the corner of the room and
opens the closet meanwhile monica and
nitsuki sit across from each other still
feeling awkward i take a seat next to
monica so
i know you really didn't have any plan
on coming here but we'll make sure you
feel right at home okay as president of
the literature club it's my duty to make
the club fun and exciting for everyone
i'm surprised there are more people in
the club yet must be hard to start a new
club you can put it that way not many
people are very interested in putting
out all the effort to start something
brand new especially when it's something
that doesn't grab your attention like
literature you have to work hard to
convince people that they're both fun
and worthwhile but it makes school
events like festivals that much more
important i'm confident that we can all
really grow this club before we graduate
right natsuki well i guess natsuki
reluctantly agrees such different girls
all interested in the same goal
monica must have worked really hard to
find these these two yuri returns to the
table carrying a tea set she carefully
places a teacup in front of us before
sending down a teapot in the middle you
keep all tea set in this classroom don't
worry the teacher gave us permission
after all doesn't a hot cup of tea and
help you enjoy a good book i don't trust
you yuri
i don't trust you ah i guess
and don't let yourself get intimidated
yuri's just trying to impress you
that's not it insulted yuri looks away i
mean
i meant that you know i believe you
well tea and reading should might not be
a pastime for me but i at least enjoy
tea i'm glad yuri family smiles to
herself in relief so mark what kind of
things do you like to read ah well
considering how little i've read these
past few years i really don't have a
good way of answering that
manga
i mutter quietly to myself half joking
natsuki's head suddenly perks up looks
as if she wanted to say something but
she keeps quiet
not much of a reader i guess well that
can change what am i saying i spoke
without seeing thinking after seeing
yuri's sad smile anyway what about you
yuri well let's see he retraces the rim
of her teacup with her finger my
favorites are just usually novels that
build deep and complex fantasy worlds
the love of creativity craftship
i've already read this this is all
things i've done the same thing same
horror a lot of horror a lot of horror a
lot of horror yep hang on yep yep yep
you know what yeah why is that well
yeah i've read this i've all done this
i've done this i've done this done it
done it done it i've done this i've done
this how is this gonna get weird
uh-huh let's go home and write a poem of
our very own
i don't like this
i don't like this at all
oh yep yeah this is all the same hang on
we need four wait oh i'm defenseless
against these girls
okay
all right
sorry i'll join the literature club one
by one the girls eyes light up oh my
goodness really do you really mean that
morb yeah it could be fun right you
really did scare me for a moment i mean
if you really just left after this i
would be super proud
i'm so happy we can become an official
club now thank you so much for this
you're really amazing i'll do everything
i can to give you a great time okay
oh thanks our guys okay everyone i think
with that we can officially end today's
meeting on a good note everyone remember
don is assignment right
wait what yeah
wait
i look forward to see how you pre
express yourself
okay all right
oh boy
okay i'll see you tomorrow then i can't
wait
so
uh with that i depart the club room and
make my way home no way my mind wandered
by natsuki yori and of course monica
will they really be happy spending every
day and after school in a literature
club perhaps i'll have the chance to go
closer to one of these girls
all right
i don't like this you've unlocked a
special poem would you like to read it
sure yeah
stare at the doctor i don't trust this
i'm staring at the dot don't you bear
don't you don't you [__] dare jump
scare me
oh stare really close at you
don't do it oh i love you oh
okay
oh
hmm
smile
oh boy
hurt oh boy sure oh boy
uh
effort bliss
wrath um
dazzle awesome
wait oh wait hang on wait
wait wait wait wait wait
massacre there was suicide in here there
was suicide
i'm gonna see what happens if i click on
that one
shiny
echo supplied did i miss it i might have
missed it
suicide
okay that didn't do anything i guess
or
rose
lay
out okay all right then
okey dokey hi again morp hey
okay we didn't run away nope
okay all right
what was that wait what did i just see
well did i just see something
no
you dive headfirst in the literature
when you wha
i saw something done
oh ah hi you're in front of the tech
monica
[Music]
manga is literature
what
how do
[Music]
i don't like this i don't like this i
don't like this i don't like this i
don't like this i don't like this
okay all right
uh you looking for something in there
[__] monaco
she never puts my stuff back in the
right spot
all right well that's nice manga yup
manga in there sure is manga in there
the manga that's in there that's manga
all right
oh boy
there it is okay all right well cool
great whoa don't judge
in fact
okay
good god oh
holy [__] holy [__] my dad would beat
the [__] out of me if he found this
okay all right okay all right that's
weird okay all right oh oh she's asleep
that's different hey natsuki yeah
suddenly natsuki collapses straight into
me hey
ah
no no no oh geez natsuki are you okay
uh
here monica reaches into her bag and
pulls out some kind of protein bar she
throws it in natsuki's direction
natsuki's eyes suddenly light up again
she snatches the bar from the floor and
immediately tears off the wrapper i told
you not to give mum
she didn't even finish her sentence
before stepping it into her mouth don't
worry more she's fine it just happens
every now and then that's why i always
keep a snack in my bag for anyway why
don't we share bombs now
okay monica you want a little bit
straight with monica making a real water
button
okay hi mark having a good time no no
i'm not nope no i'm not since you're new
and everything if you ever have a
suggestion for the club like new
integrities i'm always listening don't
be afraid to bring things up okay all
right keep that in mind gonna be of
course i'll be afraid to bring things up
because everything's freaking horrible
here
anyway i wanna share your poem with me
it's kind of embarrassing but i guess i
have to don't worry more we're all a
little embarrassed day you know but
that's sort of a berry wall learning to
get past soon
okay all right
i like it cuter it's cute it's real cute
makes me think of natsuki okay yeah sure
okay yeah okay
all right if you're interested in
natsuki then always keep a snack on you
she'll cling to you like a bubby
natsuki dad doesn't give her lunch money
or leave her any food in the house so
she's in a fussy mood
sometimes she just loses all of her
strengths and shuts down
like earlier
this is a guess but i think she's so
small because her malnutrition is
interfering with her adolescent growth
but hey some guys are into petite girls
you know what sorry just trying to look
at the bright side where anyway do you
want to read my phone now don't worry
i'm not very good cause i'm pretty
confident or someone who claims not be
very good well that's because i have to
sound confident that doesn't mean i
always feel
let's read it then
hole in the wall okay is this the same
poem as before hole in the wall but he
wasn't looking at me confused i finally
glanced at my surroundings my eyes
burned but my burned eyes can no longer
see color
are there others in the room are they
talking are they simply poems on flat
sheets of paper the sound of frantic
crawling playing tricks on my ears the
room begins to crinkle closing in on me
the area i breathe dissipates before it
reaches my lungs i panic there must be a
way out it's right there he's right
there swallowing my fears i brandish my
pen
okay that's weird so what do you think
it's very free form if that's what you
call it sorry i'm not really the right
person to talk for feedback that's okay
kind of style has gotten pretty powerful
powerful performed out loud it can be
really
i'm not sure how to put it because you
could say i had some kind of epiphany
recently been influencing my bones a bit
an epiphany yeah something like that
kind of nervous to talk about deep stuff
like that because it's kind of coming
out strongly maybe after everyone is
better friends with each other anyway
here's monica's writing tip of the day
sometimes when you're writing a poem
your brain gets too visited if you try
so hard to make it perfect then you'll
never make any progress as far as you
can tidy up later okay if you keep your
pen in the same job for too long you
just get a dick big dark puddle ink so
move your hand and go with the flow
that's my advice for today okay all
right thank you
thank you thank you
thank you
how about natsuki
first this time around hey okay we'll
start things that i don't like first of
all um what that's like he rereads my
poem never mind i don't feel like giving
you my opinion eh what's the point of
sharing in the first place i wrote this
one i could have been doing other things
in fact remember how i said i wanted to
read your poems that's what i had in
mind when writing this i want to help
you feel comfortable enough to share
yours like monica said
well i would be more comfortable sharing
if it wasn't you're really bad you're
supposed to show me a dumb poem and make
me go how well it's not that great but
let me show you what real literature
looks like and you went and ruined it
hope you're happy
so in other words you're saying you
liked it
natsuki's retorque it's caught in your
throat
ew your show you just you don't
understand anything do you no i don't i
don't understand anything that's going
on
all right
never actually said that okay all right
let's just keep going then i guess
something tells me
ah eagles can fly it's the same one
monkeys collide quickly ah people could
try that's about it it's good it's good
it's good
okay something tells me this matters a
lot less than what's actually going on
here so i'm just gonna skip again okay
yuri your turn yuri okay well haven't
seen anything
different yet
oh
you're reading tandem
[Music]
whoa what the hell
where whoa
without that music
okay all right well okay
uh
okay
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
all right okay diddy kong
racing ah
i don't like it make it stop
[Music]
i'm very stressed it's like the sonic
drowning sound
[Applause]
yuri oh hi yuri oh hi natsuki
okay cutting yourself what the [__] is
wrong in your head yeah go on let wait
let morph here what what are they saying
wait what the [__] ah suddenly you're
returned toward me as if she knows i was
standing there
she she's just trying to make me look
bad that's not true she started it
what how did you get drunk
[Music]
oh that's okay
nope yuri nope natsuki yuri natuki yuri
natuki
gary natoki oh hi
um
hey morp why don't we step outside for a
little bit okay
sorry about that
they really shouldn't have tried to get
you involved it's probably better for us
to stay out of this we'll go back inside
once they're done yelling
some president i am right can't even
confront my own club members properly i
just wish i was able to be a little more
assertive sometimes but i never have an
interview to put my foot down against
others you understand right anyway if
this makes you want to spend less time
with the others then that's fine i'd be
happy to spend time with you instead
suddenly natsuki runs out of the
classroom
oh
she quickly runs away oh dear well looks
like they're done
i didn't mean it i didn't mean it i
didn't mean it yuri's rocking back and
forth in her desks and her desk with her
palms on her forehead yuri i didn't mean
it at all i believe you i have no idea
what yuri might have said to natsuki or
did morph please don't hate me please
i'm not like this there's something
wrong with me today it's fine yuri we
know you didn't mean it beside i'm sure
natsuki will forget about it all about
it by tomorrow completely
anyway the meeting is over so you can go
home if you want or he looks at me like
she wants to say something but she keeps
glancing at monica you can go first
monica i'd like to say a little bit
longer i'm the president so i should be
the last one out i'll wait for you to be
done
well i'm vice president so please let me
take the responsibility today kind of
sounds like you don't want me around for
something yuri it's not that it's not
that
i didn't get much of a chance to discuss
my book with morph it would be
embarrassing for you to listening
sorry i guess i don't really have a
choice do i i'm sorry for causing
trouble but i really appreciate
[Music]
okay so maybe i shouldn't have clicked
that one disaster contamination
valentine imagination oh hi oh happiness
extreme uh
extraordinary existence
fantasy a hidden congruent raindrops a
melancholy a hard dark plier
whirlwind
how about going on an agonizing journey
another day passes terrible i made it
already sure it is okay all right sure
it is yeah okay i've gotten a little
more comfortable here over the past few
days under the club around the usual
scene greets me welcome back mark uh hi
yuri i'm not sure if it's me or if
yuri's expression but the weight of
yesterday's quarrel still hangs in the
air a little um here glances over her
shoulder looking around the room
natsuki's reading a manga at a desk
surprisingly monica isn't here yet
telling yuri takes my arm and pulls me
to the corner room
about yesterday i i really need to
apologize nothing like that has ever
happened before and something just came
over me i guess i wasn't acting mentally
sound please don't think we're usually
like this not just me but nitsuki as
well yuri i'm happy that you were
considerate and apologized you don't
have to worry too much even though i've
only been here a couple days i could
tell something was off yesterday maybe
we were just a little extra sensitive
because it was our first time sharing
poems but whatever it was it didn't make
me think any less of you i had already
decided that there's no way you can be a
bad person and now that you're paulie i
i retract that statement i think there's
a way you could be a bad person i know
you really didn't mean it ah morph
don't say those kinds of things so
frankly they make me a little too happy
i'm really glad that you're such an
understanding person and i'm really glad
that you joined this club everything is
a little bit brighter with you around
and ah sorry what am i saying right now
i just
hey have you guys seen monica why
no i haven't i was also kind of
wondering where she was
man yuri i'm guessing you haven't either
yuri is clearly taken aback by how
calmly natsuki is addressing her no i
haven't jeez this isn't like her at all
i know it's stupid but i can't help but
worry a little
huh why why are you looking at me like
that um natsuki about yesterday i just
wanted to apologize i promise i didn't
mean any of the things i said and i'll
do my best to stay under control from
now on so yuri what the heck are you
talking about i have no idea i really
don't remember anything at all did you
do something yesterday no it's jeez
whatever's on your mind i'm sure it was
nothing i don't even remember anything
bad happening
okay you're the kind of person who
worries too much about the little things
aren't you ugh
but i'll accept your apology anyway if
it makes you feel better about it
besides it's kind of nice to hear since
i was always afraid of you secret
hallowed and hated me or something like
that
no not at all i don't need you
well you're kind of weird but i don't
hate you either
that's who he turns to me you're still
on trial though hey suddenly the door
swings open sorry i'm super sorry oh
there you are i didn't mean to be late
maybe you guys weren't worried or
anything nah well natsuki was i was no i
what took you so long anyway
well my last period was study all to be
honest it kind of just looks like the
time piano and all that okay all right
well piano piano wasn't where you played
music okay all right well then
okey-dokey then
well i'm working on writing a song but
it's not quite done yet maybe it wants
to get a little better it will that
sounds cool i look forward to it is that
so in that case i won't let you down
morp okay monica smiled sweetly weird ah
i didn't mean any pressure or anything
like that oh don't worry i was hoping
that i could share with you anyway i
guess that's why i've been practicing so
much recently i see i'm not sure if
monica was referring to the whole club
or just me in that case best of luck
thanks so i didn't miss anything did i
no not really
i chose not to bring up anything the
three of us talked about besides natsuki
has already run off into the closet
morph um since your compliments put me
in a good mood i was wondering if you'd
like to spend some time together i mean
in the club
i suppose so i don't think i could say
no to you after that book you gave me
well i guess i need to make sure natsuki
isn't waiting for me after we finished
reading yesterday she she's fine she's
reading over there so it's okay right ah
in that case i don't see any problem
okay can we start now let's find a place
to sit
i'm being a little forceful aren't i i'm
sorry my heart won't stop pounding don't
worry about it if anything it's nice to
see you have so much energy
yeah
but i need to try to calm down i won't
be able to focus on reading like this
take your time okay
because poppy had a book after bag
what's this story about anyway well hmm
i look at the cover of the book the book
is titled portrait of markov there's
anomalous looking eye symbol on the
front cover basically it's about this
religious camp that was turned into a
human experiment prison and the people
trapped in there have the trait that
turns them into killing machines that
lust for blood and the ability to get
even worse than the selectively breeding
people by cutting up their
that might be a little bit of a spoiler
yeah
but anyway i'm really into it especially
the selective breeding of cutting off
limbs part that was really what got me
into it
the book i mean not the thing about the
limbs okay yeah that's kind of it's kind
of dark isn't it here it made it sound
like it was going to be a nice story so
that dark turn came out of nowhere ah
you're not a fan of that sort of thing
are you morph no it's not that i mean i
can definitely enjoy these kinds of
stories so don't worry i hope so yeah i
totally forgot that yuri's into those
things she's so shy and reclusive on the
outside but her mind seems to be
completely different filled with dark
thoughts and horrible things don't trust
you i don't trust you at all
it says kind of story it's kind of thing
that challenges you to look at life from
strange new perspective when horrible
things happen not just because someone
wants to be evil but because the world
is full of horrible people and we're all
worthless anyway then suddenly
i'm rambling
oh
okay
not again i'm sorry hey don't apologize
i haven't lost interest or anything well
i guess it's all right then but i feel
like i should let you know that i have
this problem when i let things like
books fill my thoughts my whole body
gets incredibly
i kind of forget to pay attention to
other people so i'm sorry if i end up
saying something strange please tell me
if i start talking too much that's i
really don't think you need to worry
that just means you're passionate about
reading least i can do is listen it's a
literature club after all ah that's well
that's true in fact i might as well get
started reading it
[Music]
okay all right i mean you don't have to
but haha what are you saying
let me just get the book i quickly
retrieved the book that i put in my bag
all right it's fine if i sit here right
slipping to the zoo next yuri i'm so
forward
okay
yeah you sure
apprehensive sorry not that i want you
to it's reading a comedy song
okay
all right okay
i can feel her presence over my shoulder
a little distracting are our thumbs
going to intertwine again
okay
she's reading for oh whoa wait whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa hang on a second
she's actually
looks like she's reading from my book
instead sorry i was just i was just
bathing in the feeling of your whoa
you were bathing in the feeling of my
body heat
you're you really apologize a lot don't
you
i do i don't really mean to
sorry i mean
okay i saw my desk
yeah
oh yeah
okay
okay here come the thumb part all right
kind of difficult to turn the page here
there we are
ah between her thumb and forefinger ah i
do the same with my right arm all right
side of the book uh turn the page yuri
slides it under her thumb there it is
after it flips to her aside but in
holding it like this we're huddled even
closer than before kind of distracting
me
is it
i can feel the warmth of yuri's face and
she's in the corner of my vision are you
ready yeah to turn the page oh sorry
can't be distracted by your thumbs
[Music]
okay
my thumb gently letting go of the page
letting it flutter over to her thumb hey
yuri this might be silly thought but the
main character kind of reminds me of you
a little bit hey
no i didn't real i don't relate to this
character at all definitely not really i
was just thinking of the way she second
guesses things she says and all that ah
that's what you were talking about sorry
i thought you meant something else about
her about how she kills people never
mind we don't even get that far yet so i
don't know why that came into my mind
yuri are you feeling all right eh here's
been a bit a little fidgety ever since
we started reading you can rest if
you're feeling sick or something your
breathing is a little am i breathing he
puts her hand to her chest as if to feel
her heartbeat i didn't even notice
anyway i'm fine i just need some water
all right don't push yourself
okay your stands up and practically
rushes out of the classroom what on
earth was that all about morph did
something happen just now
no
no i have no idea hurry was acting a
little strange i guess so you don't know
anything sorry i can't say i do are you
worried about her oh no not really i was
just making sure that you didn't do
anything to her no what no ah don't
worry i believe you silly yuri just does
this sometimes so it's not alarming
all right if you say so anyway why don't
we start sharing our poems yeah
shouldn't we wait for yuri but she might
be a while so i figured we'd just get
started without her is that okay
okay i stand up i make a medal that
where i left off in the book and
slipping into my bag
monica you wanna see my poem you wanna
see my poem monica hi again mark how's
the writing going all right i guess i'll
take that as long as it's not gonna be
bad maybe you're applying yourself
all right i want to share what i wrote
sure here you go
all right great job morph i was going to
go ooh in my head while reading it it's
really metaphorical oh okay all right
easiest for me to keep everyone's
expectations low okay suddenly the door
opens
yuri i'm back did i miss anything not
really well we all just started sharing
our poems with each other yeah already
i'm sorry for being late no need to
apologize we still have plenty of time
so i'm glad that you took all the time
you needed all right thanks monica i
suppose i should get my palm now but
anyway you want to read my poem now i
like the way this one turned out so i
hope you do too
save me the colors they won't write bt
full scullers
flash
x
piercing red green blue and
endless coffee of meaningless noise the
noise it won't stop
vial
grating
king screech
piercing sign cosine tangent like play
a ch
look board on a t
rendable like playing a knife on a
breathing rib cage
[Music]
delete her
wow
ooh
ah sorry i know it's kind of abstract
you know
i'm not gonna do that
i'm just trying to um well never mind
there's no point in explaining anyway
here's monica's writing tip of the day
sometimes you'll find your fellows
facing a difficult decision
when that happens don't forget to save
your game you never know when um who am
i talking to can you hear me
tell me you can hear me what
anything
okay that's my advisor
all righty then
okie dokie
okey dokey artichokey
[Music]
uh yuri here you go
bless me
i've been waiting for this oh boy let's
see what you've written for today
your stares at the poem with the
surprise expression do you like it morph
how did you pick up on this so quickly
just yesterday i was telling you the
kind of techniques worth practicing
maybe that's why you did a good job
explaining i really wanted to give it
more imagery your visibly swallows even
her hand appears sweaty
ah
that makes me so happy it's so amazing
you feel like i'm valued more everything
that you write is a treasure to me my
heart pounds just holding it
i want to write a poem about this
feeling is it bad more i'm not being
weird right i'm having a harder time
than usual at concealing my emotions i'm
kind of embarrassed but right now i just
want to read you to read my poem too
okay all right ah wheel
wheel
different all right a rotating wheel
turning on axle grinding bolt head
linear gearbox falling sky seven holy
stakes a dark ship a portal to another
world a thin rope tied to a thick rope a
torn harness parabolic gearbox expanding
universe tomb controlled by slipping
cogwheels existence of god swimming with
open water in all directions drowning a
prayer written in blood a prayer written
in time devouring snakes with human eyes
a third connecting all living human eyes
a kaleidoscope of holy snakes
exponential gearbox a sky of exploding
stars god disproving the existence of
god a we are rotating in six dimensions
40 gears and a ticking clock a clock
that takes on one second for every
rotation of the planet look like they
picked 40 times every time it takes us
for every second time they're both out
of holy stakes slide to the existence of
a dock ship to another world a
kaleidoscope of blood written in clocks
a time devouring prayer conducting the
sky and foraging gears an opening eyes
in all direction breathing gearbox
breathing ball there breathing shift
breathing important breathing sex
breathing god breathing blood breathing
all these things breathing human eyes
breathing time breathing glare breathing
sky breathing wheel
i should do slam poetry
it doesn't really matter what it's about
my mind has been a little hyperactive
lately so i had to take it out on your
pen
ah that is a pen fell out of your
backpack yesterday so i took it home for
safekeeping and i am i just really like
the way it writes so i wrote this poem
with it and now you're touching it
i'm okay what did i just
can we pretend this conversation never
happened you can keep the poem though
okay all right
natsuki okay
huh i like your last one better yeah
really well yeah i can tell you were a
little more daring with this one but
you're really not good enough for that
yeah that fell flat that may be true but
i just wanted to try something different
still figuring this all out you know
yeah i am fair enough you're still new
to this so i wouldn't expect you to find
your style right away i mean everyone in
the club really writes differently from
each other maybe you'll all find a
different little influence from all of
us for instance i noticed that you were
spending some time with yuri today that
[__] not that i carry you spend your
time with after all i was taught never
to expect anything for everybody so it's
not like i was waiting for you or
anything still you should at least look
over my poem you'll probably be able to
learn something from it okay
ah it's the same old spider poem that's
fine that's fine it's nice
ah not bad right it's quite a bit longer
yesterday's was way too short okay cool
cool cool this is the same
so far
okay all right well then okay man it's
weird natsuki was a tsundere and then
yuri's turning into a yandere
and then monica is just being weird what
do i do for what it's worth i respect
you well i guess thanks but it's kind of
obvious that you respect yuri more so
whatever we're done sharing so you can
leave now okay well all right oh a
special poem yes please
it's ra uh
oh
okay good special oh hey
all right oh thief then that's a little
weird okay everyone we're all done
reading each other's bulbs right yeah we
have something we need to go over today
so however we're going to the front of
the room this is about the first of all
well sort of oh do we really have to do
something
oh
it's not like we can put together
anything good in just a few days we'll
just end up embarrassing ourselves
instead again
that's a concern
i blacked out
oh wait
okay all right i don't really feel well
with last minute preparations
okay
don't worry so much we're gonna keep it
simple okay look i know everyone's a
little more lively ever since morph
joined and we started with some club
activities but this isn't the first time
for us to become complacent we still
have only four members and the festival
is our only real chance to find more you
know what's so great about getting new
members anyway we already have enough to
be considered an official club more
members will just mean everything gets
noisier and more difficult to manage
natsuki
i don't think you're looking at it the
right way at all don't you want to share
your passion with as many people as you
can
to inspire them to find the same
feelings that brought you here in the
first place
no i don't i really don't no i'd rather
not okay i just don't i don't want to
ugh
the literature club should be a place
where people can express themselves like
they can't do anywhere else it should be
a place so intimate that you never want
to leave i know you feel that way too i
know we all do so that's why she works
hard and put together for the festival
even in something small right morp
oh come on you can't take advantage of
morph to agree with you just because he
doesn't know how to say no to anything
look monique
[Music]
okay do you really think any of us here
joined the club with each other with
other people in mind yuri never even
talked until morp joined says for me i
just like it better here than i do at
home and morph isn't even passionate
about literature in the first place and
that's everyone sorry but you're really
the only one who's interested in finding
new members the rest of us are fine like
this i know you're president and all but
you really should consider our opinions
for once
you're gonna die and that's okay you're
gonna die monica is clearly taking back
my nitsuki's words that's not true at
all
i'm sure yuri and morph want to get more
members too right
i don't know about yuri but i'm kind of
indifferent if i showed as much
enthusiasm as monica wanted then i would
probably be lying sal if it's up to me
to rescue this situation
no natsuki's right isn't she this club
it's nothing more than a place for a few
people to hang out why did i think that
everyone here saw it the same way as i
did but that doesn't mean that we're
against getting new members or anything
more why did you even join this club
what were you hoping to get out of it
well
that's not really something i'd be
honest about is it in fact if i remember
you weren't even given a choice to join
or not
to choice not to join monica sits down
and stares at her desk what's the point
of all this anyway what if starting this
club was a mistake
huh
now you've done it natsuki what mei i
just spoke my mind is it a crime to be
honest
it's not about being honest it's about
word choice besides you have no right to
speak for everyone in the club like that
you don't understand at all
i just i just want a place that feels
nice to hang out with a few friends is
there a problem with the club being that
for me
there aren't there aren't many other
places like that for me
and now monica wants to take it away
from me she's not taking anything away
no more it's not the same it won't be
the same with the direction she wants to
take it if i wanted that then i could
have just joined any other stupid club
but this one i mean
at least for a little bit of time things
were nice natsuki started packing up her
things
i'm going home i feel like i don't
belong here right now natsuki natsuki
ignores yuri and walks right out of the
classroom
oh this is bad i don't know what to do
well do you have an opinion on the
festival i don't know i'm kind of
indifferent
who cares about that obnoxious brat
[Music]
i mean i like how nice and quiet the
club is right now and i'm just happy
with you here but still i'm the vice
president it's not right for me to
ignore my responsibilities like that
nobody would cry if she killed herself
wow okay well yuri alrighty then
i should do my best to consider
everybody's perspective and make the
decision that's right for the club what
about you more what do you want to get
out of this club your repeats the same
question as monica i decide giving an
indirect answer is better than nothing i
think the most important thing for
everyone is to get along
and for the club to provide something
that you can't get anywhere else
i don't think it's about how many
members but rather the quality of each
member that's what will end up making
the literature club a special place
i see
i really agree with you each member
contributes their own qualities in a
special way with each change in members
the identity of the club as a whole will
change too i don't think that's
necessarily a bad thing stepping out of
your comfort zone once in a while so if
you would like to help monica with the
festival then i'm on your side as well
alright well maybe we can all talk to
natsuki tomorrow yuri nods hey yuri
um i know things were a little awkward
yesterday but i feel like you deserve to
know that i still think you're a
wonderful vice president and also a
wonderful friend
monica i want to do everything i can to
make this the best club ever okay me too
yeah
let's all go home for today we'll talk
about the festival tomorrow
okay
all right
i look forward to it shall we go more
please don't dig this wrong way but i'm
gonna chat a little bit with more before
we no
no no i don't want it i don't want it i
don't want it i have a funny feeling
okay here's my theory right now yuri is
the source of all this it's people want
like the developers want you to think
it's monica
i'm 100 positive that's yuri
is a source of all this
because she's pretty much the only one
that actually cares about literature in
this club and why would
the extremely popular very beautiful
athletic
monica up and decide to start her own
club about something that she cares
deeply about but obviously yuri cared
more about and suddenly yuri is
i think yuri's the sorts of this i don't
know to see what he thinks of his time
here and all that it's important to me
as president here he looks a little
trouble but she doesn't protest okay i
trust your judgment monica in that case
i'll see the two of you tomorrow see you
tomorrow
okay phew things have been a bit hectic
lately morph i just want to make sure
you're enjoying your time in this club i
would really hate to see you unhappy i
feel kind of like i'm responsible for
that as president oh oh oh oh and i
really care about you you know i don't
like seeing the other girls giving you a
hard time with how mean natsuki is and
everything and you're being a little bit
you know
sometimes it feels like you and i are
the only real people here you know what
i mean but it's weird because in all the
time you've been here we've hardly
gotten to spend any time together i mean
i guess it's technically only been a
couple days sorry i didn't mean to say
something weird there are just things
that i've been hoping to talk to you
about with you things i can oh no you
only you could understand so that's why
wait not yet no stop it
yeah i don't think
i don't think i uh anyway that's all the
time i got for this episode i'm gonna
end this here
we're gonna do a dark corner of this so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know if you think down the
comments below and as always i'll see
you
in the next video
bye-bye